matt next to shine creates something
really special to look at look at me
gorgeous
i'm sir john
and in the next 30 days you'll learn the
exact techniques i use on my celebrity
clients i'm gonna demo three looks that
are gonna rock your world the everyday
look
the no makeup makeup look and
the icon we're gonna dive into my makeup
kit step by step i'll show you what to
buy what to keep what to throw away
you don't need to know anything about
makeup to take this class skin is skin
and that is genderless it's ageless it's
timeless
let's do it
no makeup makeup is all about just
adding definition using minimal products
i always work from my hand because i
don't want to pour all of my money into
the sponge you want it to go directly
onto the skin around the eyes always use
your ring finger is the weakest finger
you have think about tapping and not
disrupting
super excited to show you my everyday
look
layering is key i like to use cream and
i set it with a powder that creates a
face that will last you all day all
night always keep a couple brushes that
have no product on them as little magic
erasers i've had some of these brushes
since i was 19. if these brushes could
talk
they would need an nda
i want to show you how much fun you can
have with light reflection with
depositing color or smoky eyes start
small and then blow out the color apply
a little cream blush into the crease of
the lid this is for someone who loves
glam
my first memories of makeup was going to
be my mom i just remember her always
applying mascara or a lip and it changed
her mood there's a little bit more of a
pep in her step after she had a minute
to give herself self-care
i don't want you to look at anything
here as a mask but how can i uncover how
can i reveal more of who i am or who i
want to be the most impactful thing you
can do is to really love and be
connected to whoever you're looking at
in the mirror
and then a lipstick helps
i'm sir john and this is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you